let's talk to the work and pension
secretary terese coffey
who's here it's good to see you good
morning i mean look when you look at the
papers this morning i mean
it's depressing stuff how do you feel
about all of all of this
well the pm answered a lot of questions
yesterday um continues to
say that uh we our main priorities get
on the job whether that's about being
tackling the virus or indeed about
getting
young people into work uh which we're
doing through kickstart
uh but i think it's just part of the
ongoing aspects of uh
recognizing there's a number of uh
different inquiries underway cabinet
secretary spoke to parliament yesterday
as well
and frankly we just uh our focus is on
other things i think is the best way to
say i mean do you think mistakes have
been made somewhere along the way
well undoubtedly the um you know things
that we were discussing
actually with the chief scientist and uh
chief medical officer
you know as was suggested perhaps last
year when
certain assumptions were made about how
the virus might be transmitted we have a
different understanding of that now so
there's different
elements that have gone along the way
but the key thing is we've now got 33
million people vaccinated with their
first dose nearly 13 million with their
second dose
so it's all been about trying to make
sure that we tackle
the coronavirus and actually get on with
the road map to recovery
uh because by trying to have also saved
lives we're actually been trying to save
livelihoods and we now need to get the
economy really flowing again
away from the prime minister if you like
but on a personal level to you
if someone ever said you know let the
bodies pile high
are they comments you could ever
personally condone well the prime
minister says he didn't say them and he
said that
i think yesterday i think to sky uh and
so yeah i take the prime minister on his
word but away from the prime minister if
anybody else said it could you ever
condone it
well i'm not aware that any politician
has said anything like that so
indeed any other person i'm aware of but
there's an element here about to say
trying to keep on with the main uh task
at hand
uh we've got through this uh challenging
time we're still not out of it
that's why we're still encouraging
people to take up their vaccines but
also the work like kickstarter getting
young people back into work
yeah look i know we're going to talk
more about kickstarter in just a moment
but
um in terms of some of the other
allegations floating about and to do
with
the flat in number 11 what's what's
going on with
what's going on with that it's a
confusing picture well the prime
minister has said
he has paid for the uh redevelopment
that happened
um he's asked simon case who's the
highest civil servant in the land to
undertake a review of exactly what
happened simon was not the cabinet
secretary
when all this started uh so it's
important uh
that simon's been allowed to do that and
he said that he would
share that with um the select committee
in parliament but the point is that
uh i guess for a number of people it's
just uh while we're trying to make sure
that we get through and tackling the
virus and get people back into work
i don't think the majority of the
bishops public are in any way interested
about some wallpaper or sofas or
something like that
so i do understand um that we need to
keep
moving on as it were in terms of what's
going to make a difference to people's
lives in the years ahead yeah
i mean charles walker um deputy chair of
the
1922 committee said last night you know
to paraphrase him couldn't give two figs
about
who paid for the flat as long as it
wasn't his constituents
well i think it's important that uh you
know the prime minister will make
the declarations in the usual way these
sorts of things often get tidy up in
something called the annual accounts
uh which get published by departments
every year uh so
it's just uh the right declarations will
be made the prime minister paid for it
personally
uh and meantime uh he's out leading the
government
in trying to get back on the road
roadmap to recovery and i think we're
making good progress on that
well i mean i know you know to this
point all these allegations have
have been denied but i mean do you
accept there is a growing
perception of sleaze i mean this there
was a
there's a poll in in i think it's the
eye this morning
um saying that you know public opinion
is shifting i mean this is the damages
it whether whether or not any
allegations are true
the perception seems to be sticking what
i do see is uh being out on the
doorsteps uh campaigning which i have
been doing myself during this
campaign people are generally optimistic
they're pleased with
how we're now getting on they're excited
by the prospect of
getting this virus properly under
control recognizing it
won't go away forever but uh seeing the
say the number of vaccines
uh out there and actually life starting
to come back to normal
and so it's about uh i i genuinely
believe people are just more interested
in getting on with their daily lives
and the actions that we're taking to
help them to get back to more of a new
normal as it were post covered
what do you think dominic cummings is
playing at i don't know if you if you
had any dealings with him particularly
when
he was still working in number 10 but
what's he playing at
um i don't know he was an adviser to the
prime minister
he didn't really have a lot to do with
dwp um i think uh i had one message
about kickstart funnily enough um
last year and that's about it in my
interaction which i think is a
reflection of how with department work
and pensions have really got on with the
task
at hand and spending uh an extra seven
billion pounds on welfare in the last
year
because many people have turned to
benefits for the first time
we were able to meet that challenge but
our challenge is now to
recognize nearly a million people have
lost their jobs many
millions more 5 million being protected
by the photo scheme and we're
particularly focusing on young people
and i'm pleased that over 16 000 young
people have started their kickstart role
but we've created and approved nearly
200 000 jobs to be filled
over the next year so it's a really
exciting time
uh but that's happening more quickly now
as we move along the road map to
recovery
but i mean look i i get that there is a
need to focus on what is happening now
and what the government is working on at
the moment but
there is some concern me from william
hague former leader
of course who said with the with the
prospect of dominic cummings giving
evidence before
one of the committees william hague said
in the times i think it was it would be
a mistake to dismiss
these allegations as a fleeting problem
dominic cummings he says he's likely to
turn up to this committee with a trail
of digital evidence
well a lot of people will have seen
dominic coming for the first time ever
last year
uh when he gave a press conference in
the rose garden number 10.
they'll have come to their own views i'm
sure the public uh um
and meanwhile the prime minister
continues to get on with the key things
that really do matter to people the
people's priorities so you know there's
an element here that we have a real
level of transparency within government
we publish aspects about on a quarterly
basis
about our meetings that we have those
sorts of things so it's it's important
that we
say keep focused parliament does its job
of scrutiny which is doing
uh and we uh as i say really focus on
things like helping people
get back into work well and in terms of
that and the kickstart you know
i think it was about two-thirds of those
who've lost their jobs during the
pandemica
are under 25. it is very difficult for
those people to get places in employment
16 500 places is impressive in itself
but there's still a you know we're
talking half a million people here so
you're absolutely right stephen and i've
got to get people back up and running
quickly haven't we you're absolutely
stephen i'm conscious
um with aspects of the lockdown it's
proving challenging to get some of these
jobs
uh kind of underway but we've seen a
real uptick in the number of employers
opening their doors getting young people
in
giving that sort of training that job
experience
later today i'm going to a leading
retailer again to look at how
they've taken on nearly 300 people and
they're going to be learning a variety
of tasks
and opportunity experiencing
opportunities during their time
with the retailers so you know we are
trying to provide
opportunities for people so they get
that first um first foot on the ladder
of getting back into work
what's what's the the the appeal to
employers for this as you try and get
more people
into this scheme as businesses reopen
well kickstart in particular is
actually the flagship scheme of our plan
for jobs more broadly where we're trying
to help people of all ages
but employers get basically wages
subsidised
25 hours free employment in return it's
a mutual benefit they have to provide
that
sort of real role but also the
employability support
so young people are ready to get the
next hopefully long-term job
can i just ask you quickly about nazanin
zagari ratcliff i mean
hugely distressing for her and her
family and friends
about what's happening the foreign
secretary says the uk is going to do all
it can
what can we do what options are on the
table well i think that we just keep
making representations in the standard
uh diplomatic way
um i'm conscious that you know this is a
decision of the iran regime the iran
iranian
judiciary system and just as we have
tried to support this family along the
way we will keep doing so and keep
making the case
on why we don't think this is
appropriate uh and in order to try and
get
uh nazarene reunited with her family as
quickly as possible
there's coffee it's good to see you this
morning thank you